tomorrow quarterback Colin Kaepernick
will work out in front of the NFL teams
for the first time since he last played
professional football nearly three years
ago
Kaepernick began kneeling down during
the national anthem in 2016 to protest
police brutality and racial injustice
against black Americans in this country
since the end of that season no team has
offered him a contract
yesterday CBS News special correspondent
and CBS sports anchor that's James Brown
spoke to NFL Commissioner Roger Goodell
and asked him about this upcoming
workout which is all scheduled for
tomorrow good to see you James he's got
to be here we all know that colin has a
lot of detractors but he also has a lot
of supporters people would like to see
him back on the field why did the NFL
decide now is the time to give him this
opportunity an opportunity
it truly is I know there are a number of
narratives out there it absolutely is an
opportunity there were a number of teams
inquiring of the league throughout the
season about his football readiness and
that they wanted to check him out this
is the best way to maximize the more
than dozen teams that will be there it's
gonna be significantly more that's who
what have representatives are absolutely
Tony that's and that's the number so
rather than have him do 12 or more
individual workouts why not max it just
for him absolutely so this is not a PR
stunt because that's what some people
have said if if it was a PR stunt they
ought to fire the PR director because
this is the worst thing that they can do
it was a major distraction when they did
do it the season is going exceedingly
well ratings are up why would you make a
move like this if it was a disingenuous
people want to see if he can play he's
up to the level of the integral but
owners are probably also gonna ask him
hey we know you're passionate what form
is that passion gonna take a app so
lowly hey Tony
that's real-world if we come to CBS I
was telling Geller they said you have to
wear a green dress you have to wear a
blue suit you have to determine do you
want to play by those rules that's a
fact
his passion should not be the waned at
all but the matter is what form is that
passion going to take because it could
be a distraction I'm going to ownership
and there are still players who are
still kneeling absolutely
but Colin is the face of it so clearly
he's gonna bring a lot more attention to
it then whoever else who may still be
doing JB what do you think are the real
chances of Kaepernick plays in the
league again if he's football ready if
he still possesses the NFL caliber
skills that he showed back when he
a quarterback in San Francisco somebody
will take a chance he's a number last
year there were 15 teams that had
injuries or starting quarterbacks who
were benched the backup quarterbacks
took over most of them are very mobile
and getting it done there have been 16
of those occurrences thus far so you
need to have a very capable backup if
Colin shows he has NFL caliber skills
and it was dangerous his capability
moves and he had before he'll get a shot
well he said that he's been working out
every single day every day every day he
says MIDI is certainly ready so what are
the teams specifically looking for and
who ultimately makes a decision on
whether he gets to play I hate like in
every game in life the boss makes the
determination about what loss yeah
whoever the owner is you know the CEO
here Susan's our rescue whatever they
make the ultimate decision about whether
or not because they've got a factor in a
number of elements in that decision but
again if he still has that escape
ability he's got a great arm yeah can
you still you know read the defense's as
well as you did before this is at the
highest level of football and you've got
to have the ability to adapt and adjust
the game is changing so you're seeing a
lot more exciting quarterbacks Lamar
Jackson no deshaun Watson
Russell Wilson continues to be the face
of it the owner makes a decision when
one argument was well owners and coaches
aren't going to be there tomorrow so is
this really a waste of college yeah but
you know what no because they hire a
staff who's tasked with the
responsibility of determining what good
talent is and if they aren't doing that
job they get fired believe me they're
going to be a number of team personnel
people who will be there videotaping the
owners will see it as well Kaepernick
Wow's them but we'll raise questions
about why wasn't illegal last two years
JB thank you that's a conversation for
the break David thank you very much